but I found my next run oh geez turn
around
dildos coming out of the ground it's
rising bold mighty impenetrable dildo
thunder right yeah slender man
all right Lindy I'm gonna put a I'm
gonna turn him into a rocket whoa okay
it's Lindy he didn't like that very much
barely you ready Wade as ready as I'll
ever be great ride slender yeah let's do
it
all right I could spawn thrusters
against thank you Bob you know it'll
cheer you up okay you ready to go man
detaching engaging it didn't work Wow
dance dance dance on the Slendy man wait
how do i how do i oh well things
together okay hold it there and
right-click it to the object do bad
you're gonna go okay fine I'll dial it
down I'll dial it down
oh I don't I right-click it to the
object Oh work no make the I object
dancing fool so oh they're gonna go this
is gonna be quite a
here okay okay I'm going gossip got some
ideas now yeah do you
oh no oh god what is happening Oh what
the hell thank you well is that wrong
where are you getting those specialized
specialized specialized specialized it's
got it yeah we're specialized under yeah
I figured out how you figured out dummy
damn not big enough
i am i working mark can we make this a
thing i'm not big enough what the rocket
what's in it
where it is found it wait that's not big
enough that's what it's not big enough
bob is this how big it was bob it's
bigger - bigger martin god i know yours
parents oh I have an idea
well that work okay it's laying it into
the ground Bob how's your rocket coming
along whoa it actually looks like a
rocket thoughts gone for ya is it
aerodynamic probably not
okay well we'll see what happens I just
need to put a chair on it you want me to
do that cuz I can do it please do it
without breaking everything wooden chair
yeah whatever it's some stupid class in
there all right okay alright put this on
here - idiot ya [ __ ] idiot [ __ ]
intelligent people are here working now
somebody get on yes somebody get on okay
wait get on it wait get on there this is
the idiot part that's it you look so
polite sitting there alright ready I'm
gonna raise it up
oh no wait no just press numpad 8 numpad
8 it'll go wait Han I gotta let go of
the chair okay there we go it's good to
go
there's no patty try and fire you
upwards wait I think the problem is
there's no stability on that so hang on
we should put some wings on it yeah yeah
hang on let me show you how to really
build some good I got an idea do your
own thing I got whatever you take your
idea Oh God
so you do thing Bob I got this just wait
just wait it's gonna be the best best
thing that's ever happened is it oh okay
okay I do like that my design plan
worked in it totally sit haha I totally
like sits up on the ground because of
the way that yeah what's uh what's going
on over here bud
well it's where who's doing one now
what's uh what's happening who me yeah
no nothing
life life treating you well yeah can't
complain that's good which what's
building but oh oh okay it looks it
looks pretty rockety is this gonna be
the rocket off to end all rockin offs
you better believe it
you guys ready to see something no no no
you ready to see something should I
attach more thrusters and random places
here Mart no okay
I'll remove them you're gonna ride this
you want to be a stubble ride don't you
a stubble rebel where are you guys I'm
decorating my rocket look it like mines
the best where is it
Oh
that's got it's gonna be it's gonna work
now mine's got aerodynamic bears they
help it aerodynamic are you ready for
this
oh no I I clipped into my okay all right
everyone watch everyone watch I'm
watching I'm watching I'm watching go
baby go
all I could switching a third person for
this beautiful everyone gets to see
woody blast off in three two go Bob
something happened to my rocket what is
this thing that happened I don't know
look at it it's not quite right here
where's your rocket turned into stump
that's cool
everyone chill the [ __ ] out uh wait I
want you to ride mine not that I don't
trust myself but uh this takes a special
hand all right
I'm gonna be inside it when it takes off
I just want to get the visual is holding
my rocket in the air weird you start
firing the thrusters and I'll see if I
can unstick it I'm trying to unstick
everything I'm not getting anything
unstuck Oh God
thumbs hold no oh we got a jiggle
someone's jiggling there's some jiggling
going on up here some wiggle jiggles um
Sark is the chair up top still stuck
wait let me orient it let me orient
taking on you
the bear stabilized doing their job
Maxie I'm trying just look at Max's arms
going up and down around her boobs
okay I have to ride this thing you want
crap engaging launch sequence in three
go on there we go by this guy oh my god
can I get up oh you can see a smoke into
Woody's hedge which oh oh there he goes
ooh had some fun with it now yeah like
destroy everything right okay all right
let's see what we can do
am i stuck it or just randomly throwing
thrusters no no no not random geez this
is why you're not in charge of building
anything wait mine I supposed to get in
the chair now oh yeah whatever well fix
it oh okay
I fixed it or that's fine okay what
thruster are using mark the big ones No
Oh Bob okay if I'm doing okay Bob I
trust your judgment but gotta add in
some stabilizing thrusters that I can
control can I put in bears it's gonna
make it spin like crazy so that it's
more in control that's my plan can I put
more bears on it
yes many bears as you up man thanks
thank you
go Chris uh-oh see wait Bob lets me be
me I'm gonna put some secret thrusters
in fun spots okay what what are the fun
spots exactly who's writing this you are
I fit the thruster limit so let's see
what happens
Oh Bob I see where you put them oh I see
what you're doing yes that'll do much
for the torsional velocity on that metal
core did you look inside the right
cylinder yeah looks good to me
that's good pray at this properly
properly okay ready wait hold it
engaging primary thrusters gonna count
down
okay
we might you're stabilizing fares worked
perfectly
thank you your internal-external Roger
system is beautiful right so what
happens if you're going in Reverse and
I'm going in forward and switching wait
so what happens if I stop pushing my
buttons
probably chaos chaos as I had originally
anticipated forwards back forwards
backwards dirty mark this is getting
dirty hang on I'm like riding a roller
coaster my arms are going up and down
what do we do hold that I'm gonna rope
this to your old one so it's still like
stuck yeah I think it's sort of stuck in
some sort of crazy abyss of suckiness
well okay miss Merrow
I roped that one to the ground what
could possibly go wrong no no let's see
what happens
alright ready yep wait who's on the
rocket oh I don't understand the physics
of this I mean I guess it couldn't
actually exist in real life so the
physics are all sort of just made up but
I'm really baffled by what's happening
right now I just want to say that me too
it's just kind of flow okay
it's tried hard to get that little one
going I meant like nine frames a second
with this
well that's cuz your computer sucks oh
whoa what's he getting Sonia Phil huh
what'd you say wait didn't Erie what on
you don't ask Bob I don't understand
it's sort of just stuck in midair right
now damn it and I'm not firing anything
are you fire oh no no no yeah someone
roped it too
I did I did that I wrote wait hang on
we're not moving
I'm stuck in a fence I'm removing my
rear oh god oh god why did you make me
do that Bob I lost one - what'd you do I
don't know lost one it's working it's
working
what the hell is happening missing I
think it's a rocket penis I think it's a
fitness cannon playing off of the penis
skin Hey few years later
yeah good job everybody we can come out
here today
this isn't [ __ ] possible alright yeah